hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe
this is our first Q&A session this is
associated with the first idea video
that we did on conservation conservation
of momentum conservation of energy
things like that so if you haven't seen
that video I recommend you go back and
look at that these are the various
questions that I've gotten that either
appeared on the YouTube channel or on
Twitter or on the blog or somewhere I'm
not gonna try to make an effort to go
through every single question what I'm
gonna try to do is to sort of coordinate
what I think were the best questions
perhaps coalesce and consolidate some
questions that are on more or less the
same topic and just to be clear maybe
this was not clear enough when I put out
the call for questions this is not an
ask me anything kind of situation this
is me trying to address questions that
came up during the video so if you want
to have and ask me anything
by all means join the patreon for
mindscape podcast and there I actually
do do and ask me anything but this for
the biggest ideas in the universe we're
going to be talking about questions that
arose during the actual video now for
the most part I'll be consolidating
different questions together so I won't
be attributing questions to individual
people but there will be exception so
our first question today comes from on
Twitter at diesel Boise whose Twitter
name is up my own butt and location is
poo poo comm so on the Internet
no one knows that you're at poo poo comm
but you're allowed to reveal it if you
want to do that and the question is
actually really good one the question is
roughly speaking what about conservation
of mass we talked a lot about
conservation of energy conservation of
momentum
what about conservation of mass this is
something we've heard of right so I
didn't talk about that and the answer is
mass is conserved approximately but not
exactly in the real world in Newtonian
mechanics in the usual way that you
would do Isaac Newton's particles
bumping into each other etc the kind of
context that we did talk about in the
previous video then indeed mass is
conserved and that is an interesting
conservation law but Einstein comes
along as we'll get
- in later videos and unifies space and
time but he also unifies a whole bunch
of other things so he helped us
understand what energy is what mass is
and so forth you all know the famous
formula e equals MC squared energy
equals the mass times the speed of light
squared now this is an easy formula to
miss understand it does not say that
what energy is is the mass of something
times the speed of light squared it's
not saying that energy is a form of mass
what it's saying is in a very specific
concrete situation when you have an
object with mass and that object it does
not have any other kind of energy the
object is just sitting there this is
what is called the rest mass of an
object okay so this is not the total
energy this is not an equivalence
between matter and energy in any form
this is saying there is one particular
kind of energy called the rest energy e
sub rest if you want to do that and that
energy is equal to the mass of the
object times the speed of light squared
when the object is moving when the
object is at a high distance I had a
high elevation so it has potential
energy there's all sorts of other
energies that it can have and those are
added on to the energy that you have
here or even multiplied in if you go
into the details of special relativity
but the point is whenever an object is
just sitting there with mass it has a
certain kind of energy energy remember
is not a substance it's not a thing it
is a property that something has and
neither one of these sides of this
equation is conserved okay because
energy can be converted from one form to
another right you can turn kinetic
energy into potential energy or
vice-versa
likewise rest energy can be converted
into other things that's why this
formula became so famous because it came
about around 1905 when Einstein invented
special relativity but it became very
fearsomely demonstrable in the 1940s
when we invented nuclear weapons nuclear
power what you do in a nuclear reaction
is convert a heavy nucleus in the
reactions that we actually have in the
simple atomic bombs you turn a heavy
nucleus into several smaller particles
okay several smaller nuclei and other
particles and if you took all of the
mass of the heavy nucleus to start and
figured out what that mass was and then
he took all the masses of the particles
you created at the end the mass of the
particles you created would add up to
less than the mass of the particle you
started with and I keep saying particle
because as someone who's more of a
particle physicist and a nuclear
physicist the same thing is true when a
neutron we talked about neutrons
decaying into protons and then you have
a little electron going out there and a
little anti neutrino going out there if
you take the mass of the proton the
electron and the anti neutrino and add
them up you get less than the energy
than the mass of the neutron what
happened is some of the rest mass of the
neutron converted into the kinetic
energy of the proton the electron and
the neutrino same thing happens in
nuclear fission a heavy nucleus will
decay will turn into several lighter
nuclei whose total mass is less so mass
is not quite conserved energy is
conserved in Newtonian mechanics or even
this special relativity version of
Newtonian mechanics but mass is not
conserved that's why we did not talk
about it the next question which is sort
of an interesting one one that I maybe
should have mentioned where does the 1/2
come from in 1/2 MV squared this is
kinetic energy right and it certainly is
provocative to compare that to momentum
MV now why is that provocative
well it's provocative if you know a
little bit of calculus we're not going
to assume that you know any calculus
whatsoever even heard of calculus in a
forthcoming video we will talk a little
bit about the principles behind calculus
but we're not going to do any of the
equations any of the math really but
here is something that people who do
take calculus know that if you take a
expression like mass times velocity
and you integrate it which is to say
that you add up the accumulation of this
as you change the velocity then the
formula for the integral the total
accumulation of M times V is exactly
one-half MV squared so you can kind of
see this in a very simple example so
let's imagine that you have some
quantity X like the position of a
particle that is changing over time
there's time and let's imagine it's just
a straight line at constant velocity
which is equal to 1
ok so x equals T and you want to say
well how much has accumulated of this
quantity X what you could do is just
take this distance right this is just a
triangle this is just in fact a
equilateral triangle it's exactly one
half of a square right so the area of
the square is just x squared because
both sides are size X this is size X
here and this is size X here because
this object we're considering is moving
at x equals T so that's the whole square
what about the triangle will the
triangles just one half of the square
right so the area of the triangle is
just 1/2 x squared so when you have
something that is changing linearly with
time at a constant rate of change it
very often happens it always happens
that the total accumulated amount of
stuff is given by 1/2 the thing squared
so that resembles this one-half MV
squared time versus MB so is there a
sense in which kinetic energy is like
the accumulated amount of momentum and
the answer is yes there is very much
that sense now it's kind of unusual it's
not the usual thing we do when we take
an object and we push it when we give it
energy by propelling it with some force
or something like that and we try to
figure out well how much energy has it
accumulated over that process we usually
integrate we sum up all the
contributions over time
or over distance or something like that
this is really saying let me draw a line
to distinguish here this 1/2 MV squared
versus MV is really saying that if you
have an object and you propel it okay so
you're pushing it so you're increasing
its velocity then the total energy that
it picks up is the accumulation of
momentum as the velocity changes so
basically for those of you who know a
little bit of calculus kinetic energy
can be thought of under the right
circumstances and you can just go to the
internet and they will explain this to
you
in more detail but kinetic energy is the
accumulation of momentum let me not do
that momentum freeze that calm as
velocity changes so for those of you who
are not experts in calculus or don't
know that much about calculus or don't
care none of this will have been that
enlightening but I want to say that you
know for those of you who are wondering
where the 1/2 comes from in 1/2 MV
squared
does it seem related somehow to an
integral of momentum which is mV
the answer is yes you can figure that
out you can do all the math it all works
ok next question was from fin skin
Skowronski if the antineutrino has a
charge of zero then the neutrino should
have the charge of zero that's true so
why can't a neutron turned into a
neutrino so I said that a neutron right
can turn into a proton an electron and
an anti-neutrino I draw it here in these
pictures as if the neutron and proton or
stationary the electron and the neutrino
are moving very very quickly that's just
because because the electron neutrino
are so much lighter it typically happens
that in this kind of interaction the
proton isn't moving very fast if the
neutron was not moving very fast whereas
the electron and the anti neutrinos zip
along at a very high velocity so this
can happen but what about this other
thing we're in
Tron just goes into a neutrino now this
can't happen
okay this obviously can't happen because
of conservation of energy the reason why
the neutron could convert into proton
electron and antineutrino is because
there's different things you could
imagine the electron and the neutrino
doing so as the whole interaction can
simultaneously conserve both energy and
momentum that is very very crucial for
this kind of interaction whereas a
neutron just turning into a neutrino the
mass is different right and e equals
mc-squared the rest mass whoops the rest
mass is that and you can't make it move
because momentum is conserved so if the
neutron is stationary then the neutrino
would have to be stationary afterward
otherwise you change the momentum so the
mass is going to be different and
therefore the energy is going to be
different
there's no way for a neutron to convert
into a neutrino while conserving both
momentum and energy at the same time now
that's not the only thing in fact that's
a very simple thing but in fact it turns
out there are more conservation laws
than I let you know about okay you
shouldn't be surprised at that we're not
done with the series there are a lot
more conservation laws let me just
mention a couple of them so one of them
is baryon number what is a baryon if you
know about quarks baryons are particles
that are made of three quarks so a
neutron is made of three quarks and up a
down and a down a proton is made of
three quarks two ups and a down so these
are examples of baryons and the total
number of baryons in the universe in
every experiment that we've ever done is
conserved we've never seen baryons turn
into different numbers of baryons the
neutrino is not a baryon so neutron has
baryon number one proton has baryon
number one a little neutrino which has
no quarks in it at all
has baryon number zero okay so you can
never turned something with nonzero
bearing on number into something with
zero barian number at least as far as
we've ever seen experimentally now we
have theories including the standard
model of particle physics that say in
principle baryon number can be violated
okay so in that case you might imagine
that interactions like this souped up so
that energy and momentum are conserved
and stuff like that but interactions
like that might happen this is crucially
important because an anti neutrino I'm
sorry an anti Neutron and bar that's an
anti Neutron so this is an anti up quark
in to anti down quarks antiproton to
anti ups and an anti down this has very
on number minus 1 as does this so if you
were in a universe where the total
baryon number was zero you would expect
the total number of protons and neutrons
to equal the total number of antiprotons
and antineutrons that doesn't seem to be
the universe in which we live we think
that the universe has more baryons than
anti baryons so we need something called
baryogenesis there's a little bit of a
cheat I'll explain why oops this is the
creation of baryons out of no baryons
and in order to do that you would need
to have some interactions that violated
the total number of baryons and like I
said it's easy to imagine such
interactions actually happening we just
never observed them in the lab so when I
say you need something like baryogenesis
that's a bit of a cheat because you
could just put it in as an initial
condition you could just say the
universe started with more matter more
baryons than anti baryons
but that seems somehow aesthetically
unpleasing that doesn't mean it's false
but at least it would be simpler more
elegant if the universe started with
zero baryon number and then you created
the barrier number dynamically in some
way of course because we think that
there are in nature interactions that do
violate baryon number the problem is
actually a little bit strong
than that if you started out the
universe very very close to the Big Bang
with a net asymmetry of particles like
protons and neutrons over antiprotons
and antineutrons you would prop you tend
to wipe them out right you tend to
eliminate the difference because the
total barrier number is not conserved in
most speculative scenarios of
high-energy physics so you might work
yourself into a corner and you need to
get out of it by some process of
baryogenesis you need to explain why
there's more matter than antimatter
there's other things that go into it but
I wanted to get the basic ideas on the
table there's another thing that is
conserved which is lepton number and
that's just the number of electrons
Neutron neutrinos muons and Tau's Eagles
are the heavier cousins of electrons so
the total number of leptons is conserved
where again an electron has L lepton
number equals plus 1 an anti-electron
positron has a lepton number of minus 1
so this explains why when the neutron
decays remember we made an anti neutrino
and I wasn't always but tried to be
careful about explaining that was an
anti neutrino that was made well a
neutrino has lepton number of plus 1 an
anti neutrino has a lepton number of
minus 1 and look what happens when you
have a neutron going to a proton an
electron and an anti-neutrino so baryon
number is plus 1 for the initial state
which is just a neutron the lepton
number is just 0
there's no leptons hanging around
whereas at the end the baryon number is
again plus 1 for the proton plus 0 for
the electron and plus 0 for the anti
neutrino they're not baryons they don't
at Berio number one way or the other so
that adds up to plus 1 and that matches
you started with very a number plus one
we ended with baryon number plus 1 the
lepton number is zero for the proton
plus 1 for the electron but minus 1 for
the anti neutrino and that adds up to 0
so the baryon number is conserved from
the start to the end so is the lepton
number if the antineutrino had been
replaced by a neutrino that would have
lepton number plus one and the lepton
number would be going from zero to plus
two in this overall interaction that is
not allowed that's why it's important
that's an anti neutrino that is made
when a neutron decays okay so now listen
Gupta has a very good question did
Newton look up Galileo's work or did
Galileo look up of a Senna's work or did
they build their ideas independently so
Newton absolutely knew about what
Galileo was doing we talked about
Galileo helping to really establish the
mathematical relationship of momentum
being conserved Newton built up all of
classical mechanics from which you could
derive the momentum was conserved you
don't know because I'm going to edit it
out but if you see cuts in this video
it's not so much that I'm making a
mistake but one of my cats
Caliban is playing behind us and he has
a little stuffed mouse and he's about to
tear down the green screen behind me so
I will occasionally have to get the cat
out of the way sorry about that
so Avicenna is the persian thinker who
we mentioned was the first to say that a
particle all by itself moving in empty
space without any air resistance would
just continue along at a constant
velocity did but that was like the year
1000 that was hundreds of years before
Galileo so did Galileo even seen it
would be closer to his actual Persian
name did Galileo know about even Sina uh
I actually don't know you know I looked
up this a little bit so it's clear two
things number one people knew about even
Sina there were people in Italy at the
time who had read these Persian and
Arabic works from hundreds of years ago
and commentated on them and also Galileo
knew about some of that work I don't
know whether Galileo specifically knew
about even seen his work or not
sometimes you know he might know about
it but not know that he knew about it
right because it sort of had percolated
through the atmosphere of people who
were talking to each other we see some
records of what people wrote we don't
know
what everyone said in the 1600s
informally right over coffee or wine or
whatever it was so we don't know where
the Galileo is influenced but certainly
those ideas were in circulation at the
time it wouldn't be surprising if there
had been some influence there okay one
one final really simple question before
we get to some more subtle ones Ian says
I think you mentioned that objects move
at a constant velocity in a vacuum what
is the value of that velocity so that's
just sloppy language on my part when I
say that objects move at a constant
velocity in a vacuum I'm not saying what
the velocity is different objects move
at different constant velocities but
what I'm saying is once an object is
moving if nothing acts on it if no force
changes its velocity in any way then the
velocity will just keep going the
particle will keep going in a straight
line with constant velocity whatever
that velocity is going to be there's no
Universal velocity for things moving in
a vacuum okay now there's a couple of
questions which added up to the idea of
where does energy or momentum go where
do they go and this makes more sense for
momentum so where does the momentum go
in a collision and depending on how
familiar you are with conservation of
momentum etc this might be a really good
question or a perfectly obvious question
momentum doesn't go anywhere it's
conserved right but think of it from the
point of view of one of our balls of
silly putty in a inelastic collision
okay so the balls come toward each other
they smack into each other and then they
just stick into a big blob okay so
there's momentum in each individual blob
before hand they add up to zero because
momentum is a vector quantity
so there's momentum this way this way
will mentum that way since they're
pointing in opposite directions the
total momentum is zero so the total
momentum is zero both before and after
the collision but if you think about
momentum as a thing as a substance that
sort of in here's
one of the particles in one of the blobs
then when you're living on one of the
blobs your momentum disappeared you had
momentum then he hit another blob and
your momentum went away now there's a
total zero momentum where did it go this
is exactly why you should not think of
momentum or energy as things as
substances as fluids now there was a
time and that was a conventional popular
way of thinking things like heat was
thought of as a fluid that moved from
one thing to another but it's not the
way to think momentum is not a thing it
is a property momentum is the answer to
the question when you take the velocity
of the object and multiply it by its
mass what do you get okay so there's no
place that the momentum went the total
momentum of the system is zero before
and after there's no law of conservation
of the momentum of individual pieces
that are interacting with other pieces
this in fact leads to exactly the next
question which is this whole property
set of properties we talked about of
conservation laws make sense if you have
a closed system a system that is not
interacting with anything else
of course the momentum of a particle can
change if I push it right if some force
acts on it then of course the omentum is
going to change that's exactly what's
happening here this other blob is coming
in hitting the first blob and their
individual momenta both changes so
that's where it goes it doesn't go
anywhere it's not a thing that has to go
somewhere it's just a quantity of
property that you calculate the bigger
question then is what about the universe
okay is the universe a closed system
does the universe have a net zero change
in momentum and energy and electrical
charge over time so I think the simplest
answer to that is yes by definition
right if we thought that the universe
was being acted on by something else
okay if there was something other than
the universe that was pushing things
inside the universe so that the
conservation laws that we thought should
work overall didn't seem to apply in our
universe then we would read
define the universe to include that
thing that was pushing us around okay
now this is a tricky thing because maybe
you think that you know ahead of time
what the universe is and you don't want
to let me redefine it in some way so
there is an empirical question which is
more precisely stated as if you have an
object like the Voyager spacecraft that
is just flying through space
flying through vacuum and you imagine
that you can control or at least a limb
perhaps eliminate any resistance from
the interstellar gas or heat being
radiated from the spacecraft or anything
like that so there really are no forces
acting on it is it actually true that
the velocity of that object remains
constant with respect to some other
object in a similar position over time
all of the evidence that we have says
yes but it's an empirical question right
in principle you should tour try to
measure these things when we say things
like conservation of energy conservation
of momentum and so forth these are
empirical claims about the workings of
the natural world which you should
actually test so this question is the
universe a closed system oops
capital use universe is it a closed
system all of the evidence we have says
yes you can always redefine it so the
answer is trivially yes but there's
still an interesting question whether or
not it acts like a closed system in
empirical circumstances and that's
something where we're going to have to
do experiments and find out let's see
there's a couple more big-picture
questions one is symmetries and nerves
theorem okay that's not really a
question but I'll tell you what the
question is there's a well-known fact
about physics called nerds theorem
Emmeline earther
I mean earther was a famous
mathematician in the 20th century and
she proved that when you have a symmetry
in physics under certain circumstances
there's details I'm not going to go into
then there is a conserved quantity
associated with that I did not talk
about this fact in the video this got
certain people outraged but that's just
because I didn't talk about symmetries
in the video and maybe if you hang in
there symmetries will be talked about
later on but let me just let you know
right now there is a relationship
between symmetries and conservation laws
it's not a perfect relationship you can
have conservation laws which are not
based on symmetries but when you have
symmetries you always get conservation
laws so maybe the better way to do it
would be that okay symmetries imply the
existence of conservation laws that's
nervous theorem and we'll get to that
later on it's an important theorem it's
crucially important that's why
physicists get sort of a little bit
hyped about it when you don't seem to be
paying it proper respect okay two more
big-picture questions and then we'll be
done for this video one is what about
general relativity general relativity
Einstein's theory of gravity
okay says that space-time is curved
number one it says that space and time
are combined together to this thing
called space-time that was the insight
of special relativity general relativity
says that space-time is curved again
we'll be talking more about general
relativity as the videos go on but it's
an it's a relevant thing to bring up in
this particular context because the
symmetries of spacetime in general
relativity are not necessarily those of
special relativity special relativity is
just where the speed of light is
constant etc but still space-time is a
fixed unmoving background so in
particular space and time are the same
at every moment in space and time it's
just empty space not doing anything
that's special relativity in general
relativity
things can change the universe can
expand for example so if you go back to
the symmetries and nerds theorem well so
what are the symmetries that give rise
to the conservation laws that we were
talking about before
so time invariance that is to say the
laws of physics are not changing over
time gives rise to conservation of
energy and spatial invariants that is to
say the laws of physics do not change
from place to place that gives rise to
conservation of momentum neither one of
these invariants in time nor invariants
in space need to be satisfied by things
moving through a curved dynamical
space-time now there are subtleties here
okay because in general relativity where
space-time has a slightly different
nature than it does in pre relativistic
physics the definitions of energy and
momentum are slightly different you
cannot add vectors at different points
in space-time for example in general
relativity but it's okay it's fair to
say that in general relativity energy is
just not conserved let me give you an
example the universe is expanding so we
think of the expanding universe
here's space at one moment of time and
then if we have time going up those of
you who just listened to my podcast on
mindscape podcast of Lyra board its key
will know that time going up is a choice
that we have to make that other people
will make differently but space gets
bigger
that's the expansion of the universe
okay the universe expands which means
that different galaxies have a bigger
distance between them the total amount
of space increases between them so if
you take galaxies so here's a little
galaxy and there's the same galaxy over
here but there's there's another little
galaxy over here spiral galaxies okay
they move further apart if you imagine
that each guy
Aleksey has an energy and its energy is
equals MC squared because galaxies are
basically stationary they're basically
just sitting there and they have a lot
of mass then the total number of things
in this expanding region of space stays
more or less the same the energy per
thing per galaxy stays more or less the
same and therefore the total energy in
this region of space stays more or less
the same and you might think well good
energy is being conserved even as space
expands but then someone points out
there are things that are moving in the
universe okay there are photons for
example here's a little photon moving
through space and it is a feature of the
expanding universe that as space expands
the wavelength of the photon gets
stretched this is the redshift
okay the cosmological redshift a short
wavelength blue photon will be stretched
to longer redder wavelengths over time
the energy of a photon goes up as its
wavelength goes down a short wavelength
photon has more energy in it than a long
wavelength photon does so the energy of
the photon at this early time is more
than the energy of the photon at this
later time energy did not stay the same
the energy was not conserved like I said
there are subtleties here and you can
sort of try to come up with a definition
of energy that includes what space-time
itself is doing that turns out to be
very subtle and difficult to do it's not
an easy or obvious thing but you can try
to do it and there's some issues there
and I'll mention some in a second but if
you just talk about the energy of the
stuff in space-time and you want to know
is its energy conserved as the universe
expands then the answer is simply no the
energy is not conserved and in fact not
only can it go down like it does for a
bunch of photons a bunch of photons lose
energy as space-time expands you can
also have energy in empty space itself
so imagine like diagrams getting crowded
but imagine a little box in space
okay there's a little box in space so
this is literally just a little region
of space of fixed size one cubic
centimeter so later on the box doesn't
expand okay
the box is the same size by definition
I'm taking a fixed cubic centimeter of
space but there are more cubic
centimeters okay there's more of them
more boxes are being created there is
something called the energy of the
vacuum the energy of empty space what
Einstein called the cosmological
constant it is an amount of energy that
is fixed per cubic centimeter of space
the number we think actually exists in
the real world the vacuum energy is one
one hundred one 100 millionth of an ERG
tenem eyes eight eggs per cubic
centimeter okay that's a constant fixed
number even though space is expanding so
in this region where we said the number
of galaxies is staying constant so the
total energy in the form of galaxies or
particles planets stars anything like
that that energy is staying constant the
energy in photons is going down but the
energy in vacuum is going up in that
region because the energy per cubic
centimeter is the same as the region
gets more and more sizable more and more
cubic centimeters in it all of that is a
hundred percent perfectly compatible
with the laws of physics it's just that
the laws of physics are a little bit
more subtle when you're in a world with
an expanding space-time so it's not that
anything can happen okay there's an
absolute clear definite rule that says
how the energy changes as the space time
beneath it evolves over time so you're
replacing one rule the total energy is
constant with a different rule that says
the energy changes as the universe
expands in this very definite way but
the rules a little bit more complicated
so I think that even though you can sort
of try to muck it up by adding things
that include the energy of space-time
itself for intuitive purposes it's
perfectly okay
to say in an expanding universe energy
is just not conserved finally then what
about quantum mechanics so quantum
mechanics you might also guess we will
talk about and create a length later in
the series but let me just say one
feature about quantum mechanics which is
that we describe quantum systems using
what's called a wave function so if you
have position X ok this is where a
particle might be in classical mechanics
it's located somewhere there there is
the particle at some value of x in
quantum mechanics no no it is not that
in quantum mechanics there is a wave
function generally denoted sigh of X and
it is spread out over space I'm sighing
because physicists don't agree on what
the wave function is there are some
physicists like me that says that the
wave function is an exact representation
of reality this is what reality is it's
not a particle sitting there at some
location it's a wave spread out others
will say no no the wave function is a
way of making predictions and the
prediction we make is the following when
you observe the particle you don't know
we're gonna see it all you can do is say
what the probability is and the answer
is the probability is given by the value
of the wave function squared so there is
high probability where the wave function
is large there's low probability where
the wave function is small well we know
though
putting aside those ontological
questions about what is actually real is
that when you observe it the wave
function changes and then we're going to
details about what it means to observe
something but now we're just being
sloppy about all that stuff what happens
for all intents and purposes is that
when you observe it you only ever see
particles in a specific location you
never see the wave function spread out
all over the place so the wave function
changes to be at some particular
location okay at some particular
observed value of
the particle is so we say the
wavefunction has collapsed and people
who care about interpretations and
foundations of quantum mechanics will
argue about what that means and we'll
explain that later but this is
empirically what more or less happens
the fact is you can calculate an energy
for the wave function there's a formula
that you can plug in and the energy
changes from before to after okay the
energy of this wave function before we
observed it is different than the energy
of the wave function after we observed
it now you might say well that's okay
that doesn't surprise me because the act
of observation is an interaction right I
had to look at it of course probably the
energy that was in the wave function got
exchanged with me or with the
measurement device or whatever was
actually doing the observation so it
turns out no that is not actually
sufficient you can show that the energy
really does change the energy of the
whole system the system you're looking
at plus the observational device plus U
etc it really does change under the act
of observation if you believe my
favorite version of quantum mechanics
the many-worlds interpretation different
branches of the wavefunction that are
created when you make this observation
will have different energies but the
total energy the energy of the
multiverse the energy of all the
branches of the wavefunction at once
stays the same so in many worlds energy
is conserved but individual observers on
different branches of the wavefunction
don't see the same energy from time to
time whereas in the good old-fashioned
Copenhagen interpretation if you take
seriously the idea that the energy of
the system is the formula for the energy
of the wave function that just changes
so either you have to say that energy is
just not conserved or you have to give
some more rapid song and dance about how
the energy is not what the energy that
you thought it was I'm not quite sure
what that song and dance would entail
really so anyway I wanted to go through
both these examples quantum mechanics
and general relativity appear because
they're lessons right I mean things
like the conservation of energy the
conservation of momentum absolutely
crucial to the way that physics
functions to a the natural world
functions but they're not sacrosanct
they're not things that once we
understand them we're not allowed to
question them anymore physics is a
breathing living thing at least if you
count physics as not how the universe
behaves but our understanding of the
universe our understanding of the
universe is never perfect it hopefully
gets better but it certainly changes
over time so things that you might have
thought we're absolutely inviolable
principles things that could not
possibly be violated once you understand
how the universe works better it might
be that those principles are just
special cases that are approximately
true in the right circumstances but not
true more generally that's a lesson for
us as physicists and maybe a lesson for
us whenever we think about the world in
any context whatsoever